hello I'm Paul Carla with from
independent and welcome to this week's
coffee talk if you wanna find out more
about fill of dependent you could check
us out from independent or guerre the
organization behind the Spirit Awards
and multiple events throughout the year
again from an event done all got also
ships so today we've got two very
exciting young creators with us first up
he's someone I've known for quite a
while since he was a fellow in our
project involve program he's probably
best known for creating the phenomenon
dear white people which started life as
a in the hit movie before coming on
becoming a long-running Netflix series
which has had three seasons so far that
the fourth season was coming up his
latest film is bad hair which premiered
at the 2020 Sundance Film Festival last
movies to ever see a live audience and
he's also the host of the KCRW podcast
don't acne which is coming back later
this year it can be found on all good
podcast platforms so it's good to see
with us
I could friend Justin Simien they Justin
how are you hey I'm good man I'm stuck
in my house feels good I think G Nicks
is not she's outside right now I'm
outside this is um this is a cafe and
yeah with us
joining Justin today is director known
for the lemon and the upcoming Zolo
which also debuted at Sundance this year
also numerous TV episodes including
Atlanta dear white people Mrs America
divorce and one of my favorites here and
now which was short-lived but I loved it
janek's of Bravo's with us a gen Xer
it's so wild right that oh you can see
that people are here I was like it just
it's just us we're like in a chamber
peace there are people listening in and
you actually started you
to directing from like the costume
design award directly
yeah just like Joel Schumacher started
in costumes and then I am because I get
I don't always get asked about costume
stuff but when I do I generally will
cite Joel Schumacher as like the person
that I know that did that and the
reaction is generally something of like
a confusion like not knowing how to
process which i think is great because
then it's over so the way these work is
I'm going to step off this virtual stage
I will come back to some questions we'll
try and get to as many questions as
possible anyone tuning in you can use
the Q&A button at the bottom of the
screen there to submit your questions
and wonderful thank you Paul oh hello oh
hi kinnexa this is so funny right it's a
reads Redux of the last time we got to
talk so I'm I hope I hope they don't
expect us to talk about film and stuff
because I just want to catch up like how
are you oh you know I'm actually I I do
want to know how you are the last time
we talked was was it two weeks ago it
was two weeks ago yeah yeah and I think
the world is still on fire but it was
the fire was the fire it was
particularly hot it was particularly hot
when we talked high and close so I think
it's I think because racism just started
I think at the end of May it just around
Memorial Day weekend was the beginning
of right and that was so interesting
because I hadn't really seen or
experienced it before and then right
around right that day it had really
opened up for me as I imagine it had for
you also
mm-hmm well because dear white people of
course was just you know me like come
planing and bringing up things from the
past that we were already over so to see
racism start teller so you were you were
pulling from the air it's like a fantasy
yes so it's nice that the fantasy can
meet the moment by the way I have to I
have to do a very not at all humble
super name-drop a gross humble brag
about you really
I was talking to Ryan Gosling oh you
were he remembers me he remembers you
about how much yes and and I was so
jealous cuz he's seen Zola and I haven't
seen it and I'm he was telling me how
great it was
he's mean it he's seen it girl by the
way I'm just gonna say like so many
white people have seen it that like I
don't even that I know them that I don't
know like a random white person will
just and I'm saying they're white so for
those listening that's what's happening
okay I randomly just write me and be
like loved the movie oh you're seeing it
that's yeah look they have their own
cinemas that are corona free if it means
I'm getting a job if it means
something's coming towards me like I'm
here for it
but I can't believe he remembers me we
met as a costume designer he told me
about that yeah and we just want to pass
that on he loves you well thank you he
used to also work out at the same gym
that I worked out at Hollywood YMCA
which if you know what that gym it is
not sexy it's like children and old
people it's like all all ages all
abilities it's great it's a thing it's a
little screwed gym if you want that I
mean you're not going now because you're
not going anywhere
and I hate working out I'm fine I'm fine
so okay artists questions what are you
like how are we gonna meet this crazy
ass moment me obviously racism just
started we're filmmakers who have been
imagining I guess racism up until this
point but now we can actually speak to
it enough work at last
what do you how are we how are you
meeting this moment like what are you
what's in your mind right now
what are you working on and how are you
integrating it yeah I mean I think when
last we spoke and this is this is
shifting for me I was feeling you know
at a hundred days of quarantine 120 days
whatever the number is I was feeling
pretty I'm creative and I felt guilty
and sad about that and somewhere early
someone had planted this seed that
something to be effective on the other
side of this like how much have you made
and I don't mean honey I mean like but
ant the tangible object right the right
self and I and it was really eating away
at me and no yeah I felt sort of
destroyed cuz I was like well I think at
the end of this I will have myself I am
just like grappling and grasping at my
own sanity and well-being um but I've
come out on the other side of it I mean
were you feeling creative during those
first hundred days 40 days 50 days were
you feeling like no I wanted to stay in
bed I wanted to stay under the covers I
mean there was like a kind of forced
creativity because we were still writing
dear white people writers room virtually
yeah yeah we were doing the zoom writers
room which you know was is very taxing
for reasons I still haven't quite
figured out why zoom writer writers
rooms are like harder than the real
thing at your own doing a substantial
part of it having to answer the question
of were you looking at your own face
well because when you said it I was
looking directly at my own face I think
that there is I haven't read anything
and I'm sure someone is working on this
but there has to be some sort of mania
that sets in if we were at at coffee in
the writers room we would never be
seeing our own reflection and VI and it
is already taxing to do a degree of
performing right you're all like putting
on right
and then sort of be putting on the thing
and watching yourself put on the thing
and then this readjusting you know like
I've learned that like when I use my
hands like that looks good you know
certain and I'm just like that's insane
but I have been looking at my own eyes
and when you're not looking at your
expression you're looking directly into
someone else's digital eyes it's like in
a writers room like you can look
anywhere here you can look at your oh
and you can look at the what like you're
having these like very intimate and
intense conversations with people and
you cannot look away from either your
are their face going in the bathroom
right I know that seems goofy but
something like going to the bathroom or
oh yeah where I've been in a I've been
on something and then be like oh no I
suddenly have to because like my I
haven't regulated my life to like for
this to make sense and then I need to go
to the bathroom or you need to eat and
then you're just like you know in a
prison of sorts where you can yeah and
I'm just gonna keep it real because it's
just me and you and possibly several
others I don't know but there was a
couple moments in the early days where
you know wearing like shorts wasn't
great for my writers room because when I
would get up you know a little but which
you know I would moon them actually and
there are several lawsuits because of
that so we you know it's been a hard
road for everybody but it was nice it
was nice to have the show to pour it
into I think at the beginning of Ko vid
it was we're making the show but we're
making it for a future that we don't
completely understand
and since racism started recently it's
been interesting because I'm like wow
like everything we had to say even then
in the hypothetical bubble of CO vid
like is incredibly it maybe even more
pertinent than it was then like we
couldn't have possibly anticipated how
pertinent was and for me I don't know
and I'm curious about your experience
about this like you know there is a it's
different this time kind of energy
around the racial conversation I
I think what has continued to surprise
me is is what isn't different that's
like there's a lot of virtue signaling
that's new from people that we've never
heard it from before but behind closed
doors I'm still I'm still a privy to the
the same amount if not more exasperated
sort of conversations than situations
how have your professional relationships
with white people then I it has happened
less now but I would say 14 15 days ago
I got a lot of messages from people that
just said I'm sorry and that was really
I was already exhausted when I read that
because I don't want to engage this
because then I have to say I ever have
to say it's okay or I have to say it's
not okay and I say thank you which feels
weird and then I can also like I can see
the road where I'm gonna like bammy
somebody through their apology of
whatever either their own behavior or
just like the world and I'm like I don't
got time for this I still have a list
going of people that I need to respond
to that row and it just keeps getting
longer and I'm just like I don't want
that I mean look I have what I have
well-meaning white boos who I'm just
like girl it's fine you know but then
there is a list of people whose numbers
aren't in my context like I don't know
who they are like all right I got long
emails really long emails where people
like walk through the steps of the thing
that happened and and I'm not replying
to them I think I just don't want it you
know because it's a different it's a
different kind of it's what
victimization might be too strong a word
but it's sort of like you are you're
being put on the spot like I remember I
went to a black lives matter protest at
some point and it was down the street
from here and it was beautiful it was
mostly white people it was in Silver
Lake
everyone was kneeling in the streets and
I felt so awkward because I was one of
very few black people there and there
was something about it just felt like
there's like it was like my birthday or
so it was like everyone was like you
know when when you were
and it's we're all going to learn and
grow together I have to say it is lovely
to be able to make a very awkward
satirical comedy during these times
because there's a lot of operas inside I
bet you just said about arriving and
being the only one and being looked at I
have a sort of like thing that in my
brain which is that I remember so I
moved to the US when I was a teenager 12
13 I moved to the US and I have a memory
of being on the train in New York with
my mom and and black people nodding
right or nodding at my mom and I I it
seemed really foreign to me why just
never seen that before and like with
time I noticed that that is just
something that you do know what I'm
talking about like you're here I'm here
and and I never really like arrived at
an answer for it it was just something
that I recall and then when I moved to
LA because I seem to have seen less
black people unless I was seeking them
out I remember I had a partner who was
white a romantic partner and once we
were walking through this neighborhood
and four different black people had
nodded at me and asked oh do you know
them and I was like oh no it's just like
no we're just I'm here they're here
we're having this moment if things get
dark I think we'll find each other yes
right up here and he was like what and
so I went to protests in the last few
weeks and there were mostly white people
and white people were doing a version of
the not to me and almost like I get I
get it I see you I feel you like I'm
here with you and it stressed me out
actually it's interesting but it had we
call that thing but I was like this is
when it gets dark I'm not finding you
I'm still interesting position because
like I'm glad that it's happening I just
I am I just like but again it's like it
really is always on black people to
navigate it with like grace and wisdom
and understanding but it's [ __ ]
awkward for us to like this is a very
you know if there's something it doesn't
feel like a triumph
you've been screaming at the wall your
whole life and then finally someone
turns around and listens like it's I
don't know how I don't know what I feel
like that I'm tired I mean yeah I'd be
although right now you look very
hydrated I have to say well that's cuz I
showered and yes I thought you were
worth it and the and the participants
were worth it well I I didn't think that
I guess because I am you know in my
night-night shirt before this call
started you were telling me about what
you are watching in quarantine I think
you should tell the children listen to
the zoom - okay so I mean as I'm sure
you are I'm watching a lot a lot more
just the most and I think when this
started I when at first when this first
started I thought wow what a great
opportunity to watch all the things that
I have lied about watching and what to
build your why people totally you know
Wizard of Oz you went to film school so
it's different for you but I mean like
that list of [ __ ] that you don't see oh
it's even worse when you've gone to film
school because there's no excuse it's
like you know like what do you mean you
haven't seen the best years of our life
it's like it's like I missed it growing
that like you know AFI releases that I'm
sure film independent does it have like
the hundred films you must have seen so
I've probably lied about seeing 75% of
those and well this is a great time to
finally watch those movies so that when
I'm in meeting in somebody sites you
know that movie and I'm like yeah but
love the photography you know all the
time actually
Vavoom fall is brilliant oh not like you
know what I mean I I kind of went to
that list and found that it was actually
too demanding it had required too much
of me and for instance and this is not
meant to be any shape but one of the
things I had lied about seeing was taxi
driver Wow
I lied about seeing that one for a long
time - but you did
eventually I eventually saw yeah yeah I
I think I understand why I lied about
seeing it when I started watching it and
I think that I was always in these
circles of I went to theater school but
I had a lot of friends who are in film
school so I be it means like Circle
Jerks of white film boys being line I
can't even it's like the words aren't
worth describing it you know but it was
some energy where like we're you know
everyone's pants were down and like
their nose open and I was like yeah it's
totally love it and I feel that way too
so about I don't know 125 years ago I
started watching it and I it was an
afternoon and I was just like I just
don't know if this is that these are not
the notes that I need right now because
Martin Scorsese is in it isn't it and uh
and he in the backseat of this taxi
talks about shooting a woman in the
vagina with a gun after he says the word
[ __ ] and I was like yes you know I'm
gonna have to come back to this when
like the world's a little brighter pep
in her step because I was just like this
isn't the tenor
I need all that is to say so I was so
sad because I had watched all of the
dumb [ __ ] like the first half of the
year and if only I had known I could
have like inverted that right pasady to
watch like you know things that were
grave but my favorite thing I have sort
of a top-three but my favorite thing
that I've watched was that I've started
watching is I may destroy you
it is I'm sure you have this sometimes
where you watch something and you're
like I wish I made that I can't believe
I didn't get to make that you know you
write your reps and you're like and why
wasn't I a part of that conversation
like you're like rage out because it
feels so special it is just mad I mean I
there I don't want to say much because I
really need you to watch it and I go
there Ellard doesn't do it justice
because I think the trailer sets it up
as being a thing that well you know the
like do I want to watch this tenner
right now and I um
it's it has a heaviness I feel the joy
to a heaviness that you might be like am
I ready for this but it is it is just
made with so much care and and joy and
it is yeah it's just real it's [ __ ]
radical I can't I can't wait I can't
wait I love her and it looks great and
you know I my problem is that when I'm
working I just watched trash like I
really I know watch to be inspired I
felt like when I'm working I'm like I
need to see drag queens competing week
after week not trash that is not trash
no it's not trash I blame all just like
SVU oh no I mean like reality TV like I
need to see drag queens competing as as
highbrow as it gets I mean there's also
you know women competing for screen time
and the Beverly Hills housewives or the
Atlanta housewives those I know I know I
know I feel like it's it's the TV
equivalent of eating chick-fil-a but it
is it's fascinating especially as a
storyteller because is yeah homophobic
right like they're like a homophobic
company right it used to be and then it
stopped being and then I think it is
again I know I think now they don't like
white people or both I'm not sure the
point is is Popeyes has chicken now so
we can we just got it at Popeye's so we
can just eat it there now so um so
you're in like a housewives narrative I
am although I will say so I've been
watching this is my watching is always
weird I've been it's a combination of
all of the drag queen all of the rulers
like 14 iterations of RuPaul's Drag Race
on right now I'm obsessed with that show
legendary on HBO max okay so on HBO max
do I need it you kind of need to see the
light I don't know I don't I don't want
to tell you how to live your life but
you kind of need to see legendary
because do I need it honestly it's kind
of great because with HBO max comes
like T TCM and yes and because you know
I step with the library like anime films
like it's really got a rich like library
okay then and then there's a lot of like
gay black originals like we're here and
and legendary and legendary is is
fantastic it's like it like it predicts
a world where a person can become famous
just by being like gay and fabulous and
and like knows how to Vogue I mean these
people like these it's like it's like
America's next best dance crew but it's
all like gay like houses in the ballroom
scene and they have like bogus and it's
like a whole thing you get to leave the
stage with them like is it sort of like
I'm assuming it's in this you know Paris
is burning being like the first
iteration of that that a lot of us may
have seen yes there's there's backstory
you get to know them over the course of
the series the hosts are very
controversial in different ways it's
it's spicy I I'm so then I watch stuff
like that with my boyfriend during the
day and then when he goes to sleep I
watch like archival World War two
footage oh is that your king I it's I
just get into these I get into these
obsessions and I can't stop and I
started watching I think probably
because of Trump and the pandemic or so
I don't know why who's who who's that
who's who before you said pandemic who
was that a dump I think no Trump yeah
he's that he is he's I've been told he's
the President of the United States I'm
waiting to see you know some paperwork
to prove that but he but basically I've
been watching like Hitler document I was
really interested in like how propaganda
is works and has always worked and all
that kind of stuff and so I've been I've
been rabbit hauling in if World War two
documentaries and now I'm watching like
you know why we fight and Memphis Belle
and all this [ __ ] I don't know why guys
it's just what happens so at some point
we're not on the same I'm not a that's
Road I'm on I don't think that one's on
my Road it's fine I don't know if I
could handle that did you see 8:46 by
chance Chapelle so oh oh my god
I haven't actually stopped to watch it
I've watched like clips of it must it's
worth under a half hour
no I highly I I hate myself I walked
away from it feeling most grateful that
we get to be in the same orbit you know
I know he can he's trouble and has done
some said some things that are that
neither you or I would stand by hmm but
it was really radical especially when it
happened like Adam it came out at a
moment where I think that at least for
myself I felt I felt I didn't I didn't
know how to put the thing into words and
to go back for that thing we were
talking about it you know earlier about
like being creative in this time to be
able to like express the all of the
thoughts that are coming to your head
and to put it into this like condensed
face it was just yeah it felt it felt
like a really I I felt a release when I
right right yeah I'm highly recommend it
also as a sidebar I don't know I'm sure
you have criterion and I'm sure you oh
it's um it's really cool like fan movies
like they have movies you know I every
I'm curious if you noticed this to you
that like every streaming platform now
has like a the black playlist I see it
was for me I was like wait do they know
because I feel like if anyone knows like
a Netflix or Amazon they probably know
that you're black like they just really
I can I know I can I can feel my like
how you move in this room
The Criterion is also doing it and some
of but they brought back movies that
they had because for Black History Month
it had featured a handful of these films
that I think are harder
come by yeah yeah absolutely and I got
to watch watermelon woman which I had
never said isn't it so great I was so
angry when it was done cuz I was like
what why what we [ __ ] this industry like
why wasn't I told about this and why
wasn't like that moment happen and you
were like well what do you want to do
like what do you want to do I yes it was
so [ __ ] good and then there's this
documentary short that you must see
Suzanne Sarandon
write it down because if you don't have
criterion for those who are
participating there they're offering
movies free but they're black content
free and this film Suzanne Suzanne which
is under also under a half-hour
documentary short it's a documentary
sport and I haven't stopped thinking
about it since I saw it it's in like
like five things I've seen that have
stayed with me all right
over the last you know a couple months
and that that is one of them it is just
Wow Wow please when you watch it I can't
even really describe it but the
filmmaker it's her interviewing her
family but it's focused around one
family member in particular for Nia it's
cool it's it really stopped me in my
tracks and I think if I mean maybe if
you have like family trauma stuff it
might be tough because it right it's in
that space but it is magnitude right
well they had the one thing I was
getting into him criterion as the the
Charles Burnett sort of series which
again is like this filmmaker they're
like you never find out about unless you
look he may kill her if she sighting
killer sheep though and then you're like
right there was a lot of work and to
sleep with anger is a movie I just had
never haven't seen that one
heard about and it's in it's so fabulous
and it's like you know it's it's a
totally independent filmmaking mind I
mean his movies operate in ways that are
particular to his movies and you know
the only difference between like ham and
say a Tarantino or some or even
us today this is that nobody really knew
what to do with him at the time I guess
I could just fell in the cracks and he
watch these movies it's like how did
this fall into a blind spot this is
[ __ ] genius like we should if we're
going to talk about spike and John
Singleton and you know Robert Townsend
like we've got to be talking about
Charles Burnett as well like he's a
genius there just was and racism hadn't
started so people didn't know you know
you'd let three in and even a three you
know there was like I don't know if
there's room for all of them I mean it
has to be a hierarchy yeah yeah yeah
it's sort of tragic the idea of not
there not being able to be you know
watching one other woman watching show
thing is working going well why wasn't
there space for her and I think that it
is only a more recent phenomenon that
there could be a multitude of black
voices or a multitude of and I'm sure
other groups of other colors I don't
know when there does I don't know can
there be more Asian boys I don't know
that would be nice but it's like oh
there's the one you know and I think the
idea of being like once you've watched
one of them you're kind of like I don't
really want to do the homework or much
more you know you've seen you've seen
the totality of the black experience
really once you see the room to let more
and I'm just so tired already it's
really exhausting I get it being black
is extremely exhausting so I do get it
on something I'm started tired you know
but you know I think globally speaking
white people are a minority and yet
globally you know stories about white
people are featuring white casts are
thought to be about humanity they
thought to be about all of us right yeah
I did I'm learning that has told us that
white is invisible and yes it's not
really a race it's everyone yes the
umbrella and everything else is nice is
nice exactly and I and I think like
that's the big frontiers like okay thank
you for your dedication to black stories
and black lives but like what if we
financed and
moated nice black content as if it could
be for anybody then we're really going
to be doing something well I'm
remembering talking to you about this
when you when you're white people was
coming out and that there had been I
don't I don't want to misquote but there
been a conversation I think with your
distributor about how viable the film
was abroad yes it was before it was
before we made it it was we were looking
for financing and I got pulled into a
room with my agent at the time and
totally respect him then respect him now
he I'm no longer with that agency but I
we were I was informed that because the
movie had a predominantly black cast no
matter who we would get to play any of
the characters there were I think I
think the statistic was there was 91
percent of all of the independent film
finance investors were just off the
table and so we could only really look
at you know nine percent the typical
pile of money that most independent
filmmakers go into looking for and even
then we had to kind of look at you know
some kind of unusual sources that
typically didn't finance film but I
remember that that statistic was just so
and it wasn't it wasn't like my agent
was like being like himself enforcing
this risk he was informing me that like
91 percent of our investors just aren't
going to want to look at the materials
that's the way of the world put together
I mean that's 2013 yes that's so goofy
and so dark and I am thinking about the
mindset of that person is like what does
the poster look like right because yes I
guess there seems to be some percentage
of people that go see a movie based on a
poster yes I never met them I don't know
because I certainly have never looked at
a poster and thought oh my I must see it
yeah when I wasn't like in in the 80s I
I do remember going to the movie me like
what is that going to be but you know
the website so it's very small
and I was looking straight up and you
know I'm not friends I'm sure there are
people who do look at the thing in that
I'm just saying like their shitty
posters your cookies and vice versa
absolutely absolutely I I think I stayed
with me when we talked about that
because when I went on to do my my own
first feature where the central the
central cast was predominantly white but
there were black actors in it and meet
me along one of our leads and I had seen
a mock-up of a poster that didn't
include her like well I don't understand
and they were like well it's just like
for the European market I was like
there's so many white faces on here and
if they see a black face and they're
like you know what that's not what I
need you know what this this poster
almost got me but I caught it I mean I
just didn't believe that they look they
were looking at my face and then saying
the words to me I thought will the
audacity hi Paul Paul Paul has joined us
had it I'm here I'm here to try and
squeeze some questions in before we wrap
up so these are things you ready for
some questions
yeah my last question to to everyone
when we do this is like what are you
watching so I think we've covered that
in deep-set so with Lord world to world
war 2 footage I'm watching that should I
share screen I have watched some of
those Hitler documentaries it's there in
the depressant yeah and fascinating and
weird question here from Lesley she says
I've recently thought about the process
of accumulating inconspicuous benefits
creatively enough this means anything to
you this is so Buddhist certainly think
oh it is and I is it I think I'm
Buddhist up in here I don't know
during quarantine and this unique time
in history
has just been showing up for you and if
so how
absolutely so inconspicuous benefits is
a it's a term that's used among a group
of Buddhists that I'm a part of actually
and it basically means like the fortune
or the the good things that you're a
crew that don't come in the form of
something that's like really obvious so
for instance like if you spend months
and months working on a movie that
doesn't go well though that you still
became a much better artist and you
learned you know how to communicate
you've got there was an inconspicuous
unseen benefit to it even though
outwardly maybe it doesn't look like a
success and I would say absolutely for
me I mean I kind of need like a 100 day
quarantine minimum per year just to get
my life back on track is what I'm like
just the sheer like as an introvert who
works in a very extroverted industry
being able to just be at home and watch
movies and remember that like I like
writing like I enjoyed it I enjoyed this
process when it's not you know sort of
we're making impossible deadlines all of
the time so for me as an artist it's
been an opportunity to really refuel
that's good
answer Justin I've never heard that term
and I'm I'm going to take it with me
after this Buddhism I think my version
of that is I I feel Justin you'll
probably relate to this because I'm not
sure how what the gestation of bad hair
is but my film Zola which premiered
earlier this year at Sundance like yours
was like a three year lifecycle
now that is supposed to be coming out
you know in this window and and what I
have sort of arrived at in this time in
looking back is one not having
celebrated any of like any
accomplishment over the last few years
and how I was
had been waiting to I was waiting the
movie was going to come out and then I
would say yes to myself and then got
myself on the back and then then I was
going to release were literally release
the release and and I think what I've
kind of arrived at is being able to
celebrate myself yeah and I didn't
exactly know how to do that and I think
it's like in Congress with how I was
reared but trying to yes say you did a
good job more and and being a bit more
gentle with myself it's not I would say
one of the pluses and I'm I am it is I
think a forever lesson but it is
certainly something because maybe you
are not but I had a good deal of
mourning and grief over what the year
was supposed to be like and and now that
I have fully mourned
I mean I'm still mourning but I've
mostly done by mourn and pivot and in my
pivot I'm looking at we can't if it's
not it's not about not looking at the
end goal but I guess what the steps are
on the way to that end goal right and
right and also may I just throw in
something into your pile of appreciation
we got to talk I was able to start doing
my podcast again during the the covetous
you and I had a conversation last a
couple weeks ago and I watched lemon
really for the first time since it came
out and I just have to say if you
haven't seen genexus first film lemon
like boy does it deserve a really feel
like I feel like a bunch of critics kind
of showed their asses on that movie
because it's so [ __ ] brilliant and
what you're trying to say and what
you're you're demanding as your right to
say as a black woman I think is pretty
profound so I've enjoyed revisiting you
I must say
during this point you guys just for
Justin to boost my ego I'm felicity
praise thank you Paul for setting this
up for me i real
yeah I actually had a question for you
about like productivity and creativity
because one of the guests we had over
coffee talks a few weeks ago said if you
told me that a year ago that you will
get three months at home way no you
won't be in production you'll have it to
yourself
he said I'd probably knock out the
script or two and I haven't it's really
affected what he's you know they do
creatively and interacting to the real
world but inspires him and that's why he
couldn't put pen to paper or no type of
script yes but I'm curious you know you
talked about pivoting and like how
peasants as it surprised you how you've
managed to scratch creative itches in
different ways I mean I'm jealous that
Justin had a writers room in that he had
that he had to go somewhere I only have
just gotten to feeling creative and and
I think it's because it's like I've done
the morning I'm warned all hundred and
fifteen I don't know where we how many
days it's been but I really truly
mourned all of it and yes I wish that I
think to the effect of like oh if only
I'd known I was gonna have three months
I think my my question is more alike or
the thing I wish is I wish I'd known the
last time I saw a play that was the last
time I was gonna see a play and I mean
last time I gone to the movies I had
appreciated it because I feel that that
part of my life is so integral to how
how I process and how I move and how I
get inspired and being indoors is not
you know I feel congested I think that I
have arrived at being able to have
access to even like reading or looking
at things now just because it's been
going on for so long that I'm like oh
this is how it's just gonna be so if
it's gonna be like this we gotta we
gotta get it together
um and so I've sort of been left with no
choice in a way but yeah I don't I I
really
isn't an answer for it except that it
just at a certain point I think I got
tired of myself I got tired of my own
grief I got tired of my own moping I got
tired of its like heartbreak right like
there's it's it's I don't know who I was
breaking breaking up with the pandemic
or breaking up with my old life but some
some version of heartbreak and and not
showering and not drinking enough water
and eating chips and gummy bears and so
I did that so much so that I just was
like it's time now it's time for us to
shower and do the coffee talk with film
independent and I guess you know I some
of us showered yeah yeah I mean I look I
I am an introvert I get energy being by
myself and because what we do is such an
extroverted thing III don't think I had
that morning process in terms of not
being outside but I certainly went when
Kovac struck I was not in a great place
emotionally if I'm just being honest
Sundance's is very hard and grueling and
I think on the outside that hair
certainly looked and is a success a
success in terms of you sold it but the
process of getting that film there and
being in the midst of the last season of
dear white people it was kind of a lot
and it took me a while to warm up to
really do anything kind of like you were
Jetix a to just get out of bed and like
see the Sun but as as the days went on I
found that like because I had the time
there were things that I stopped doing
in my creative process because I didn't
have the time before but now I'm able to
do regular that's really enjoyable you
know like I've we put you know a
director is constantly auditioning for
another job you're always putting
together presentations and pitch decks
and all that kind of stuff and normally
I wouldn't have time to sort of sit
there and pick the images and edit the
you know the the the rips you know where
you sort of take clips from other movies
and put something together and I found
out like I really enjoyed that stuff I
really enjoy editing I really enjoy the
graphic design aspect of planning a
movie and just think I'm gonna have time
to do those things has for me been
really fulfilling and
just be able to watch that time for two
more questions here one from mark for
you Justin in the other change you have
you cycle what are some of the
challenges of incorporating topics from
the headlines you wish to deal with sure
I will answer that but I also want to
say there's a question about all that
jazz that must be asked okay so what are
some of the challenges I mean to be
honest with you
the challenge is never how do we make
the show relevant it just we make jokes
that we don't even realize are actually
like predicting huge social movements
like you know for instance I'll just
give you like a little bit in this
season of dear white people at the
beginning of their semester there is a
sense from white people that you know we
did it we fix racism they are sort of
like they've turned the tide they're not
being resistant to some of the things
Sam has been saying over the over the
years and because they've done it
already she essentially feels very boxed
in and since the George Floyd protests
and and racism beginning in late May
it's just crazy how much that like was
predicting the experience of being black
right now so you know honestly with the
show we're just me and the writers are
just speaking from our own personal
experience it is a show about the human
condition from a black perspective it is
about black people but it's really about
all of us and we find that sometimes
when we're making a joke or a concept or
we're talking about something whether
that is police brutality or becoming a
public victim on the other side of
police brutality or you know sort of
hero worship hero worship within the
black community these are issues that
like unfortunately are a bit evergreen
and just become more topical as time
passes which is unfortunate we get to
the last question can you look a little
bit very briefly about what we're
talking about before we went live like
how you tested the water while you were
developing the original film oh sure
yeah so the you know I had the script
called 2% which was about the two
percent black population at this white
school
and on that campus was a woman named
Samantha white who had a show called
dear white people on the radio and I
wanted to test how one white people
would react to that but also I wanted to
see if she was funny I wanted to see if
the self I was coming up with her was
funny so I started the dear white people
Twitter account to test out the voice of
Sam white and I have to say as helpful
as that was in knowing what was funny it
was also really helpful because of the
like the Pearl clutching in the outrage
from white people at the time on Twitter
was very actually very helpful in
scripting the response to Sam white in
the movie and the show so you know that
was a big tool at the beginning of that
journey and that account is still it is
it's a promotional account now that you
know Netflix is using to promote the
show on occasion and it's out there so
your voice still through through Netflix
promotion or is it not not so much not
so much I think my voice might be like a
tinge to Shady for like a corporate I
don't so the last question is from Jesse
and it's for you Janet sir you've psych
it all that jazz is on your favorite
films and Lennon features an innovative
diegetic musical number is the family
sings 1 million Matt suppose half of
musicals influence your filmmaking and
have they have any influence I love that
thank you I mean you love all that does
to don't you Justin I'm kidding me I
know I worship at the altar of all that
jazz Bob Fosse for you I met the school
of buck posse
so I one of my one of my things that I
do is that like when I finish a project
I get to watch it so I so Zola is done
but like I'm talking about the done done
when it like can't be touched anymore
and I'm like hey bring it because I'm so
close to getting to watch it because I
haven't seen it in like a year and a
half I I watch musicals all the time
you know somewhere between like watching
SVU I'll have like a musical on and
naturally naturally and the one that we
actually did reference a good deal for
Zola was The Wiz because obviously right
well because it is what I thought when I
read the Twitter story it had seemed
kind of like a modern Wizard of Oz
epicenter the character so Zola is not
so different from Dorothy who wants
adventure and wants to leave home and
then when she finally leaves home she's
like can I go back home she makes three
friends she ends up making three
lifelong friends and yeah the world of
Zola she makes three people who are you
know four never friends are four not
friends um so we were kind of looking at
how the Wiz or The Wizard of Oz looked a
bit like Zola I need to see Zola tonight
janessa color wrong color but the Wiz I
didn't even know that three weeks ago is
that true yes I watch it all of the time
that movie that you're like oh my god
this is so expensive like it's so
expensive what they're doing it's it's
out of control like that movie is like
wild because some some of it really
really does not work and probably I
don't think work then but some aspects
of it are like the score Quincy Quincy
Jones did to that score is outrageous
the cast is ridiculous the cast Michael
Diana in it it's covered up but there's
like some stuff it's just a peanut
butter cup on the house
never even though I'm a big Sidney Lumet
fine yeah get yourself something legal
to inebriate yourself and do yourself a
huge favor
there's a long section that's like what
it gets mom yeah and there's a section
that's a little bit like what's
happening here and you can feel like if
you work in film I think you can feel
budget stuff for your life okay so
there's a budget and this was shot later
because like the stuff before this had
so many people and then the stuff after
has so many people has less people but
this space requires more people and it's
like I mean I think it's supposed to be
like a financial failure right oh yeah
it was like the most expensive all-black
movie ever made and then we weren't
allowed to make movies again until like
the early 90s because of it I think but
also like it's got a lot of s in it
which is like a 70s kind of New Age cult
thing like it's got things about it that
don't work okay
but a beloved classic that I can't stop
watching Oh magical a - Ross whoo so
we're pretty much out of time people
were asked to do it where you can see
some of your recommendations
I'm a destroyers on HBO Suzanne is on
criterion Creek servo is watermelon
woman yeah we talked about I don't know
- is stuff is I I've been on Netflix for
the world war two I've been on HBO max
Netflix has a lot of great world war two
dogs including five came back
HBO max for legendary and then Hulu
around Halloween time for bad hair I was
going to ask you when can we see bad
hair and Zilla who looing Zola tonight
somewhere between now and 2021 I need to
see it at night I'm gonna try and get
you a link okay right are they holding
out for theaters to reopen I think so
I think though yeah I just I don't know
how to answer that question because I
really I don't have the answer to it and
I I know that that's some of it but you
know the news changes everyday so we're
in it's hard to have definitive answers
one thing we are engaging with is
actually invisibly yeah we are at a time
we made it as 12:55 I know you both have
to thank you so much for having me I
really no fine thank you